she's a teacher and she says you know we
don't have an american flag in our class
we've got a very different flag
during third period we have
announcements and they do the pledge of
allegiance i always tell my class stand
if you feel like it don't stand if you
feel like it except for the fact that my
room does not have a flag it used to be
there i took it down during covid
because it made me uncomfortable my kid
today goes hey um it's kind of weird
that we just stand and then you know we
say it to nothing and i'm like oh well
you know i gotta find it like i'm
working on it i got you in the meantime
i tell this kid
we do have a flag in the class that you
can
pledge your allegiance to
and it's the pride progress flag which
is different it's not just the rainbow
flag it's the rainbow flag with a bunch
of other colors and it makes it like a
racial thing she thinks that students
should have allegiance to radical
leftism so she says that's what you're
going to pledge your allegiance to
giggle giggles she's she's educating a
generation of children and she's doing a
very poor job of